they shove the lgbtq plus down your
throat you know most people don't really
care what you do in your house it used
to be you know what you do in your
bedroom is your business we don't care
but keep us out of it but it's when they
start shoving this stuff down our throat
when they demand that we must have Flags
dedicated to it where they over
represent the amount of lgbtq and
whatever Plus the trans people on TV
show when we're now having kids shows
with gay people in it where we're now
having propaganda in school where
they're pushing gay sex onto children
and explaining what that is to kids that
have nothing to do with this stuff